trägt eine figur eine waffe what the
[ __ ] also ich meine ja ich hab da unten
was und erholt zum allem ein name ist
nun kommen die damen und herren ihr habt
es bereits im titel gelesen diese
website weist alles das aufmerksame
mitglied der lukb weist schon um was es
heute gehen wird und zwar um den
akinator wirklich meine damen und herren
der klatsche auch mal das hatte ich so
lange mich hoch geladen weil sie die
nato durch kennen sollte das ist diese
person das ist akinator komisch aussehen
der flaschengeist der akinator stellt
einem fragen wie beispielsweise ist eine
figur männlich und dann müssen wir die
frage beantworten muss man eine figur
überlegen also noch mal von vorne leute
ich muss mir als allererstes eine figur
überlegen ich nehme einfach mal mich der
dumme vollidiot luca und dementsprechend
muss jetzt auch die fragen hier
beantworten ist eine figur männlich
definitiv nicht ein technisches problem
ist aufgetreten bitte versucht es
nochmals geht ja schon mal gut los ich
habe gerade einfach alles neu gestartet
freunde meinen fritz box wlan router mit
apple kämpfen um eine spülmaschine die
hat eigentlich überhaupt nichts mit dem
metern zu tun aber ich habe trotzdem
eine spülmaschine angestellten auf jeden
fall geht das ganze jetzt wieder
erkennst du deine figur persönlich ist
die erste frage verstehe ich einfach mal
auf ja ich kenne mich persönlich ist
eine figur ein trio hat definitiv habe
ich natürlich auf 9 geklickt nächste
frage ist ist deine figur weiblich
ich hab da unten schon eine stammt eine
figur aus deiner familie ja ich bin aus
meiner familie hatte eine figur dieselbe
mutter wie
nee
natürlich klar ja ist deine figur so alt
wie du ja ist sie ist eine figur war 18
ja ich bin über 800 seine figuren auto
ja ich habe ein auto hat eine für über
eine million abonnenten
er ist schon auf der youtube spur hier
hat deine figur katzen
also nichts gegen alle da draußen eine
katze haben aber hunde sind halt viel
cooler also nein auf keinen fall habe
ich eine katze kämpft eine figur für die
energiewende what the [ __ ]
b
o
harte fakten
kommt jetzt auf die frage hat deine
figur ein gesicht jetzt nicht mehr doch
natürlich habe ich ein gesicht mag deine
figur den sommer ja ich liebe den sommer
kommt deine figur afghanistan
setze ich mich für die energie
dann komme ich aus afghanistan habe ich
als nächstes vielleicht auf 40 10 an den
füßen
war ja klar trägt eine figur eine waffe
what the [ __ ] also ich meine ja ich habe
da unten was in der hohl als mal hat
deine figur mehr tausend abonnenten
degas du hast mich gerade schon gefragt
ob ich mehr als zehn millionen
abonnenten haben besitzt eine figur
waffen ein wenn ich nicht nur eine waffe
besitzt dann bin ich auch nie mehrere
ist deine figur eine flasche ja manchmal
schon ich lebe nicht in england ich bin
deutscher youtuber ja ich habe nichts
mit übernatürlichen zu tun heißt der
kanal deiner figur kontra vda ja
dann bin ist doch schon ich wohnt deine
kraft das zimmer ja natürlich hat
eigentlich etwas mit wölfe zu tun bist
du bescheuert alter ritter von contrast
ein scheiß ernst
was ich habe unrecht akinator machten
megaspaß finde ich einfach diese ganzen
fragen hierzu beantworten
der aufmerksame zuschauer sieht auch
schon dass das ganze hier überhaupt
neues design ist also in meinen früheren
videos dass er noch so aus schon klasse
hat sich der webseitenbetreiber wirklich
nach fünf jahren mal gedacht oder könnte
ich mal das design ändern ich wurde
nicht im september geboren
ich habe auch keine abkürzung von meinen
namen ich habe eine jüngere schwester ja
ich bin kein kleines kind mehr ich habe
ich habe in einer gewissen form schon
das mit blut zu tun ich würde mal sagen
wahrscheinlich weil ich das schon auf
den videos erwähnt habe hat seine figur
bei 7.000 tausend abonnenten
dk
das sind
7 millionen nein ich spiele nicht in
death note mit ich stamme nicht aus one
piece und ich bin noch nicht scharf auf
geld also ich meine ich habe schon genug
geld ich bin kein teil von einem trio
ich möchte nicht meine figur heiraten
ich habe nicht mit der schule zu tun du
denkst an die akinator sex frau bist du
bescheuert der titel von diesem video
heißt diese website weist alles haben
dass man denkt weil der akinator bisher
wirklich alles immer erraten hat was
sich irgendwie ihn gefragt habe oder was
ich gedacht habe und jetzt denke ich an
mich selbst und er denkt dass sich an
dieses ding denke
was
durch komplett feiern
du hast natürlich wieder unrecht und ich
will auch weiter fortfahren
ich mag kuchen ja ich habe inwiefern
sagt man denn ein nachname estland ich
habe im frühling geburtstag ich habe ein
zweiter kanal ich spiele in einer
fernsehserie mit ich habe nicht am 13.5
dass er mich schon dreimal gefragt beim
vierten mal habe ich dann am 13
geburtstag ist denn die figuren after
what the [ __ ] wo sind wir mittlerweile
gelandet ich komme nicht in minecraft
omega vor ich stamme nicht aus splitter
mond gehst du mit deiner figur durch
dick und dünn ja natürlich weil ich
selbst meine figur bin da hattest du
schon einmal sex mit ihrer figur
also in einer gewissen form mir
eigentlich schon ich habe nicht ins
parlament mit gespielt ich bin auch kein
fisch bin auch kein affe spielt er nicht
nur bei minecraft waren vier mit
ich glaub da war ich dabei oder ja ich
habe einen youtube-kanal saß ja früher
erraten ist eine figur ein
fußballspieler hat nein ich habe mal
fußball gespielt ich bin auch keine frau
ich habe etwas mit fordert zu tun ich
komme nicht aus schweden ich bin nicht
albanischen ursprungs ich ja
wahrscheinlich ist ja früher eine menge
minecraft gemacht aber mittlerweile
macht man nicht mehr so viel spaß und
spiele nicht in einer amerikanischen
serie ich komme nicht aus mecklenburg
vorpommern ich bin ein mensch ja die war
clever potsdam ist eine figur snp dabei
ein nein ein typ der immer zockt ein
kluger typ der zufällig antwortet und
das bild von diesem klugen typen ist
eine frau
klasse
ich antworte nicht zufällig meine figur
gehört von crafter ja spielt oder
spielte deine figur beim bvb nein
dk wenn du mich doch schon was fragst
wir hatten doch wünschen dass ich bei
konkreter im zimmer leben warum kommt
dann was mit der borussia dortmund
beschweren kann ich mich da
normalerweise eher weniger tore übrigens
falls sie zu beginn hier an der seite so
ein bisschen was nicht eingeblendet
gesehen habe das war ganz einfach aus
dem grund weil ich die seite neu starten
muss sondern hatte das ganze sich
irgendwie verschoben
aber ich will sagen wir machen direkt
mal weiter ich habe mir ins amerika und
ich bin nicht kurzhaarig
stamm kuss 1000
sein bild
die idee
100 stadt muss 100 heißt ja dann bis 100
wenn du mein video hier gerade sehen
sollte es kommt jedoch mal gern ja wie
viele abonnenten hatten der ein paar
sekunden später 3073 abonnenten hat er
liebe stammfuß 100 akinator du hast mich
circa fünf mal gefragt ob ich über 1000
ob ich über sieben millionen ob ich über
eine million abonnenten habe und dann
denkst du ich bin ein youtuber mit 3073
abonnenten
wer hat eurer website programmiert
mittlerweile sind wir schon so weit dass
ich den namen hier selbst eintragen muss
also luca econ crafter ich tippe mal auf
abstecken
ja genau der bravo sie haben eine falle
gestellt die ja ich habe dirk eine falle
gestellt
ich habe einfach nur die fragen normal
beantwortet ich würde allerdings sagen
die suche jetzt nochmal eine komplett
andere person uns war
angela merkel
die alte
nat
dann stehen hier gleich 70 sek beamte
vor meiner haustür
angela merkel wurde nicht durch youtube
berühmt sie ist weiblich ja sie ist
berühmt sie wurde in deutschland die
selter 26 sie sind der politik sie hat
ein
was sein langer nachname merkel ist ein
komplett normaler nachname reagiert
deine figur zurzeit ein land ja angela
merkel
da schauten gerät also ich bin dabei
wir suchen als nächstes mal fortnight
also wirklich das spiel fortnight ford
wurde durch youtube bekannt würde ich
sagen ein gamer wahrscheinlich nicht
würde ich sagen hat eine feste freundin
ein eltern 17 nein trägt auch keine
brille nein meine figur auch kein handy
hat keine beine sie ist keine flasche
sie gehört nicht konkreter sie hat nicht
an der em 2016 teilgenommen sie hat mich
zwei augen sie macht keine kämpfe mehr
gewissen form passiert und fordert ja
schon kämpfe also ich habe jetzt gerade
mal auf verbessern geklickt deswegen
wahrscheinlich mache ich mal kommt eine
figur aus minecraft nein hat er auch
keine haustiere er hat keinen hund hat
einen namen ja stammt stand epic games
aus schweden amerikanischen bundesstaat
north carolina also epic games kommen
nicht aus schweden meine figur ist auch
kein chef einer gruppe wie league nicht
mehr als 100 kilo ist eine figur aus
fortnight
ja
haben
krank dass er da jetzt schon
meine figuren nicht maskiert sie hat
nichts mit liebe zu tun wird keine
kleidung an
sie hat etwas mit einem computer spiele
um mein gott bot neid ja doch du hast
recht ich meine das ist ja dass die
wunde 160 mal gespielt
kell krass leute dabei wieder kompletter
wahnsinn früher wirklich drei fragen und
er hat mich erwarten mittlerweile das so
lang
er hat mich ja nicht mehr erwarten wenn
euch dieses video allerdings gefallen
hat würde ich mich sehr dabei einen
daumen hoch hier unter dem video von
euch freuen das war so ein bisschen luca
2015 konzentriere jetzt wollt ihr dass
ich öfter akinator hochladen reicht
gerne mal dinge ein mit denen ich
verbunden bin irgendwie pizza oder keine
ahnung und dann kann ich ja nächste
woche vielleicht mal neuen teil hoch
laden sie jetzt noch dran sein sollte
freunde dann schreibt man die kommentare
website
dann verlieren wir mal alle anderen die
nicht bis jetzt geguckt haben
[Musik]